el Reino Unido amanece conmocionado por
el asesinato del ciudadano británico
iraní al iresavari acusado por Irán de
ser un espía para el gobierno británico
se desempeñó en el pasado como
viceministro de defensa de Irán y en el
2019 Fue capturado por ese país acusado
de entregar información confidencial
sensible a las centrales de inteligencia
británico sobre conversaciones privadas
entre Irán y occidente sobre temas
nucleares en un vídeo
publicado por el servicio persa de la
bbc asegura que fue torturado 3.500
horas y se le suministraron drogas que
alteraron su conciencia para obligarlo a
confesar crímenes que no cometió entre
tanto el Primer Ministro Richie sunak
condenó este homicidio este asesinato y
dijo estar consternado por la ejecución
y agregó que es un acto insensible y
cobarde llevado a cabo por un régimen
bárbaro que no respeta los derechos
seres humanos de su propio pueblo entre
tanto el canciller británico James
clevery dijo que este acto bárbaro
merece una condena en los términos más
enérgicos posibles Así que podemos
esperar acciones diplomáticas
adicionales por parte del gobierno
británico para presentar una queja
formal por este asesinato la primera de
ellas es que el encargado de relaciones
exteriores de la embajada iraní aquí en
Londres ha sido convocado por el
ministro de exteriores para dar
explicaciones sobre esta